yeah I love this song Travis I love it
to invite all himself I feel like it's
our fault should be that one to you like
this boss good songs not for you right
it's not a good song no this is rick
astley I don't care he's coming back
around he's playing webster hall next
year oh cool you know what you should do
I love some say home you would go see
him in concert when they give you hear
angels on my side and then rickroll 100
times would you just yell angels on my
side from the back angel my angel hey
OMS a om as I was a fans call it yeah Oh
give you a good dancer I ain't your
daddy right angle hi mr. he won a
contest yes it's not God my dad's hairdo
you wouldn't like my dance move for fun
all same thing right this is terrible
wow this is terrible see we should we be
done a song no I love the watch him give
you going to be a fun one he's [ __ ] he
should have been on Soul Train American
Bandstand the way he dances and I should
come up with a show from this [ __ ]
century hahahahaha Jesus there's no
dancing shows now like that back in the
day yeah there's never liked dancing
with the stars and a sharp bend your
right now that's not where I know no one
knows that on nobody's right solid gold
that guys like Madame flowers yet up no
dancing with the stars is it contest
it's not like doesn't matter it's a
dance show yeah it's a show we're going
to ocular dance show right you see how I
do it right and just go ahead that's so
cool little bit that's all I do you're
really actually very good yeah very good
yeah I got I got your rhythm and I do
think that uh Dancing with the Stars
might be a more topical reference than
American band staying yes exactly all
because regular people could go on
American Bandstand it is off the air by
the white one
regular people like him already he said
he's gonna be on Dancing with the Stars
I'm not going to put that face on TV
reply was that it was it's a dance show
you look at the literal implication of
altering your headphones up everything
you deaf idiot said that he said wearing
them for an hour and no volume on
nothing coming into our history I reform
but you like the dance reference would
have just been the popular show with his
dancing it doesn't have to be literally
well technically that was this doesn't
matter a regular guy like you could have
been on American Bandstand cares about
that or solid gold with a dumb show you
and it's close I mean Jim Morrison show
business so it's close enough that you
could have said Danny I'm dancing with
the stars because he's a good dancer and
he's famous I'll try to save the
reference yeah let it go what it's over
dude I would you taught it up I can't
compliment a guy understands me you're
trying to find something negative about
me complimenting is that what's going on
it was really weird to compliment your
guy and son together sometimes the brain
around don't worry